que nous avions décidé nous avions
décidé dans le groupe le matin de voter
contre cet article est un article alibi
qui est en gros ne sert à rien qui
imposait des contraintes aux entreprises
et notamment aux petites entreprises
au-delà de 50 salariés qui mobilisaient
une opposition de des petites
entreprises notamment de la CEME moi
j'ai reçu le président de la CPME il
était aussi mesure c'était sans doute
une disposition anticonstitutionnelle
puisqu'elle n'avait rien à faire dans un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et surtout elle ne
portait ni des mesures de contraintes ni
des mesures surtout d'incitation on a un
problème avec l'emploi des seniors qui
est ce matin c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour l'emploi du Seigneur
donc ça n'était pas les entreprises moi
ce que je propose des sanctions
financières qui étaient envisagées quand
même moi je suis opposé à toute forme de
sanctions non il y avait pas de sanction
dans le texte ce qu'il faut c'est mettre
autour de la table ceux qui créent des
emplois d'abord pourquoi on en est là la
question de l'emploi des seniors on
emploie moins de seniors au-delà de 60
ans en France c'est 33% à peine des
personnes plus de 60 ans sont en
activité c'est un peu plus de 5 ans
presque 60 en Allemagne donc on a un
déficit parce que ces personnes elles
pourraient payer des cotisations ce qui
apporterait une réponse au financement
futur des retraites donc c'est un enjeu
économique c'est un enjeu social aussi
de permettre à des personnes de
travailler c'est une casse insupportable
de licencier au premier de faire partir
ceux qui ont le plus d'expérience donc
moi ce que je dis il faut une conférence
tripartite état partenaire sociaux
syndicaux les patrons et qu'on se met
d'accord pour favoriser et puis il y a
des propositions qui passent plutôt par
l'incitation ça peut être la voie de la
baisse des cotisations moi je suis
contre les sanctions contre la hausse
des impôts contre les normes la
bureaucratie là c'était un alibi
technocratique un espèce de machin qui
allait peser sur le travail quotidien
des entreprises